une dernière danse en cette fin d'année
à la commanderie 20 classes du
territoire présenté à leur famille le
travail d'une année du projet danse à
l'école pour présenter une autre spectre
qu'on a fait pendant un an presque
tendance et on a parlé de la danse on a
tout fait j'ai sauvé c'est après yeux
n'a pu faire beaucoup truqués avant que
j'étais tibet la brèche vintimille un
projet qui fête cette année ses 20 ans
piloté par la mission dense de
l'agglomération il regroupe des élèves
de la grande section de maternelle au
lycée sur le volontariat des enseignants
elle leur permet par les ateliers par
les spectacles par la création d'être
citoyen aussi en même temps que toute la
pédagogique et développé à l'école la
danse est aussi une entrée dans les
apprentissages qui permet parfois des
enfants qui peuvent être en difficulté
de trouver un domaine dans lequel ils
peuvent s'épanouir un projet pour
découvrir la danse contemporaine en
allant voir des spectacles et en
participant à des ateliers les élèves
étaient encadrés de neuf danseurs
professionnels
j'ai toujours été intéressé par la
transmission en fait et du coup
questionner aussi comment l'art bien
raisonner avec avec l'école et qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que la création
l'expérimentation artistique bien
construire dans chaque individu
depuis sa création le projet a fait
participer près de 12000 enfants danse à
l'école tend vers sa 21e année